تختلف الاوراق الواقع والوضع عنها عن
المدن الاخرى لان الزلزال هو اقتصر على
عدد قليل من الاحياء وعلى عدد من الابنيه
بخلاف ما عليه في المدن الاخرى وايضا
يختلف الجو هنا والطقس لان المنطقه والارض
يكللها الثلج حتى هذه الساعه ولكن ايضا
اللافت الى انه في هذه البنايه التي تهدمت
مع بدايه الزلزال لا زالت حتى هذه الساعه
مع ليوم الثالث عشر تقطع الطريقه الرئيسيه
في المدينه كما نشاهد هذا الطريق هو الذي
يفصل المدينه او الذي يقسم المدينه الى
الشطرين ايضا لم نلاحظ عدد كبير من
الابنيه المهدمه هنا هذه البنايه ما قبلها
كان يوجد
موضعان من الابنيه المهدمه والمحطمه
بالاضافه ايضا الى المكان الاخر الذي هو
امامنا مباشره
والذي نشاهد الان به حفاره وايضا جرافه
يقومان برفع الانقاد الى هذه الشاحنه
البيضاء المتوقفه داخل البنايه المهمه كما
نشاهد الثلج يغطي البنايات ويغطي الامكنه
لاحظنا الى ان المؤسسات والمحلات التجاريه
حتى هذه الساعه لا زالت مغلقه ولم تدب
الحياه التجاريه اذا صح التعبير بها حركه
السير هي نوعا ما شبه طبيعه في هذه
الطبيعيه في هذه المدينه الوصول اليها
انطلقنا من المدينه التي
عصف بها الزلزال على عكس هذه المدينه
علينا المرور او اجتزنا عدد كبير من القرى
والبلدات في بعضها
الزلزال عصف به ككره باكملها على الارض في
حين ان بعض القرى والبلدات الاخرى لم ياتي
عليها الزلزال ولكن المقاربات ايضا في هذه
الزلزال هنا وفي الصور عن المدن الاخرى
الى انه كنا في نلاحظ الى ان البنايات
كانت قد اطرقت على بعضها هنا في بعض القرى
التي مررنا بها وجدنا الى ان الابنيه خرجت
من اساساتها الاساسيه لان الارض قامت
بعمليات خدود متحركه فقلبت البنايات من
محمود
ان تتحدث هل هناك حديث عن اعاده اعمار هذه
المباني المهدمه هل الاولويه الان لرفع
الانقاض بدايه الروايه الى طبيعتها ما
الذي تفكر فيه السلطات حاليا
نعم الاولويه حسب ما نشاهد الان هو عمليه
رفع الانقاط وعمليه نقل
التربه ونقل الركام ونقل الحديد الى خارج
المدينه شاهدنا منذ بعض الوقت ايضا هنا
على الطريق شاحنات تنقل هذا الركام كما
شاهدنا عند اول المدينه وكان ملاحظا او
كان مستغربا ان نشاهد شاهين الشاحنات تحمل
برمتها الحديد بمعنى الى ان وصلت الامور
الى عمليه فكفكه الحديد عن الاسمنت وفصل
الاسمنت باكوام معينه والحديد ايضا باكواه
من محد معينه وهو ينقل الى اماكن لربما
الى مصانع لاعاده تذويبه بين جديد وهذه
مساله معقده وهي تحتاج الى تقنيات عاليه
وتحتاج الى جهد ولكن هنا لا جدوله للاواء
لان
نشاهد ايضا كما تشاهد معي الشاحنات هي
تحمل الاتربه هنا لا جدوله للايواء لان
الزلزال اختصر على عدد محدود ولكن
بالتوازي مع ما رايناه في المدن الاخرى
ومع ماء نراه الان الى انها كانت محدوده
ولكن للطريق هذا طريق اساسي اذا ذهبنا
الصوره الى اخر الطريق نجد كيف السيارات
الان تذهب باتجاه اليمين نشاهد ايضا
الشاحنات من هنا هي تنقل ايضا المواد كما
نشاهد في هذه الشاحنه التي تنقل الاتربه
وايضا